annyira megszokottá vált a szerat, a
durvaság, a szexualitás megmutatása.
Most aztán, hogy ki hogy éli meg a
valóságát, az egy dolog, de hogy ezek és
nem minden nem minden úgy jön le, mint
mint kritika, hanem csak mint
felmutatja, hogy hogyan működik egy
bizonyos szinten a társadalom. Nekem még
fel is pörgött a sebességem. Most
hallottam nemrég, hogy van ez a
manzőrjárat sorozat, és hogy ott két
másodpercenként vált a kép, tehát hogy
két másodpercenként valami történik,
valami más történik. És én én a
gyermekeimnek nem merném odaadni
őszintén szólva.
Ennyire intenzívvé vált már minden, és
hogyha ehhez még hozzáadjuk a
sebességhez magát az ingerküszöböt is,
akkor akkor elgondolkoztató.
[Zene]